so today I'm going to talk about some of
the problems we face that Google and
that's the where big data is especially
relevant to helping solve these issues
I'm going to focus on unsearched and
search ranking and then talk a little
bit about a nap week we just released
called called G board G boards and iOS
keyboard where we spent a lot of time
kind of building from from from the
ground up or keyboard disabled us to
predict what you type and out of
complete your words and and is as
accurate as as we can make it so we get
selling inquiries a day every day we see
queries we've never seen before we see
about at least fifteen percent of the
traffic we receive our brand new queries
we've never seen before and we have to
be able to develop algorithms using the
signals and the data that we have to be
able to find answers for each of these
queries and and for what I'm showing you
on the left here is the query why is the
ocean blue and we return an answer from
the NW NOAA's website that the tells you
why the ocean is blue and behind all
this is is our core ranking algorithm
which understands what users are asking
for and is able to surface answers from
the billions of documents that we have
in our in our web index one of the
problems we face simply building our web
indexes well which of the billions or
even trillions of web pages that are out
there on the internet should we crawl
and should we index and keep accessible
for our users and then you know how
often should we recall these pages and
as we try to solve these problems we
look at the data in terms of how often
these certain pages and certain sites
are
are impressed and our click and try to
model and predict whether a new page
that we're calling is going to be one
would be useful for users in the future
so as you look at like some of the
features that we that we build into
search and some of the experiments that
we run here's just like a screenshot of
what our desktop search looked at look
like that I think about a year ago it's
probably similar right now the queries
bakery Durham North Carolina we we
actually evaluate every single component
and experiment with every single
component of this search results page so
in the in the left on the left hand side
you see a list of of web results these
web results we run a retrieval algorithm
or retrieve web pages that we think
might be relevant we rank them and then
we display them in a manner that we
think is is consistent with what users
would expect and make making it easy for
them to interact with our search results
in every component of that is
individually and holistically of
experimented with and I'll talk a little
bit about how we go about that
experimentation process we also have ads
on the right hand side here run
experiments with ads as well as the UI
the look and feel of our of our search
results page the important question that
that we always ask ourselves in searches
is you know which way is up what makes a
better search engine what makes a better
ranking function or what makes a better
UI for search what features are good for
our users and the difficult problem with
this is that there isn't necessarily a
gold standard that we go by to determine
what the are true north is what we've
been able to do is over the last 15
years or so kind of a solidify our
vision
for what we want are our search
experience to look like and try to
encode that in guidelines that we
provide to human raters and these human
raters provided feedback on our
experiments so what we're able to do is
run run experiments provide examples of
these exams experiment queries that are
affected by these experiments to our
human raters and then they're able to
kind of help us evaluate whether a
particular change is positive in there
and in their trains opinion I'm gonna be
on that we run we run live experiments
on real teachers as well so i kinda want
to show you a little bit what these
because we get to have here i'm going to
show you what these raider guidelines
look like reloaded here so they're time
it we're in coding here instructions to
what we what we believe are important
for our Raiders to to to evaluate and
I'm going to just show you one one
section of this these are your money or
your life pages so some types of pages
could potentially impact your future
happiness health of financial stability
we call such pages your money or your
life so we actually spend a lot of time
training our Raiders make sure that they
value authoritative net high quality
content especially for for queries where
we're at thorac aeternus trucks and
quality is to make the difference
between a great experience and a pretty
reporters during in search and this
document this kind of guideline for how
we think about search is evolved over
time with respect to our thinking for
what makes a good search engine so
recently we started focusing a lot on
mobile friendliness than encouraging our
operators to spend a lot of time valuate
evaluating whether a page is is friendly
on mobile devices does it load quickly
is it easy to consume doesn't beyond
that continue to focus on whether
whether sites are authoritative whether
they whether they you know if it's a
retail business and again good reviews
and it does it have a telephone number
that's obvious or contact information
Assad based on the page so all kinds of
properties that we think make make the
high quality web page are asked of our
Raiders to evaluate now these
evaluations aren't used directly and our
ranking function that used just for to
help us understand whether changes to
our ranking function are good but the
reason that I brought it up here is to
show that is to show that there isn't
really a single objective metric that
we're trying to optimize we're really
trying to encode what we think is good
in a search engine and and hopefully
iterate over time and and get there at
the same time that we run live
experiments and we make sure that
whatever we build has the positive
hopefully it has a positive impact on
users so i'll show you like a little a
little graph we put together this kind
of goes through this data is from 2012
but goes through the process of how we
of the experiments we run and not to
scale the scale of which we run these
experiments and the funnel through which
we comes we come up with ideas and
evaluate them so the top number there's
118,000 we ran in 2012 118,000 what we
call precision evaluations where we had
where we kind of came up with an idea to
change our ranking function or UI and we
asked traders to determine whether they
thought that that that change was good
and so they they evaluate each result
and they say you know what this does
change I think is better than
or worse than what we currently have and
then we also run these side by side
experiments where we ask our Cuban
evaluators well do you think that the
left side or the right side is better
where the left side might be the
experimental side and the right side
might be what we currently have in
production and then they evaluate and
they evaluate based on these trained
guidelines that that we give and finally
we're n7000 live traffic experiments in
in 2012 where we actually take a small
fraction of our production traffic
presumably each of you or were also in
these live experiments and we we
evaluate to see how users interact with
the experimental the ranking function or
UI that we're evaluating or the control
is a production you I that that we're
comparing it against and we develop
metrics like click-through rate or how
many interactions are on the page how
often you manually refine the query and
look at those metrics to understand
whether we think that the change is good
and finally in 2012 we had 665 different
changes to our to our search algorithm
either ranking function or UI or our new
features that we launched all of which
we are almost all of which we ran
side-by-side experiments live traffic
room and went through the whole funnel
now the decision to as to whether we
actually launched a change doesn't
necessarily come down to only whether we
start going whether we saw positive live
experiments or positive human of elves
it's it's certainly still a little bit
more complicated in the sense that we
also have to think about the potential
impact of that change in the long run so
the potential impact of that change on
the web ecosystem the impact of that
change on on for example whether
whether we're you know promoting small
sites vs big sites are we doing the
right thing in the long run so the
ecosystem that Google's built on top of
and and oftentimes that that comes into
play when we when we make these make
these decisions so I wanted to dive in
in particular to one of these components
this is the component that helps us
understand what users mean when they
issue a query to Google this is one of
the comments where we use the vast
amount of data that we have from the web
and also from our search query logs to
be able to improve your searches and to
be able to you know do one
interpretation of it is to be able to
apply our natural language processing
ability at scale to hundreds of
languages that that we support for for a
google search we'll talk about sin so in
the background is that enabling
computers to understand natural language
is still one of the hardest problems we
face so it's one of the hardest problems
we see in artificial intelligence at all
I think they're starting to feed it with
some of the box that are coming out this
year and these BOTS platforms that that
many of the messaging apps are
supporting that having a natural
language conversation with with a
machine is is still very very difficult
it's still we're still at the early
stages of of making it feel very human
and real but for Google search is
critical for us to return the best
results we have a very native like a
entry point to search where you can
either stay or type anything you want
and very often the natural thing to stay
or type is by speaking in your natural
in your natural tongue your natural
language so in order for us to
understand
these these these queries we removed
need to be able to rewrite them into a
language generalizes and we can
understand so synonyms is a big part of
that so what is a synonym some are
obvious so for example pictures and
photos mean the same thing in most
circumstances if you search for pictures
developed with coffee we'll see if I can
click on it pictures developed with
coffee did you know you could actually
develop photos with coffee grinds you
can do that so someone searched for the
great pictures developed with coffee and
the first result here is how to develop
film using coffee all right and and then
you can see in the URL we actually
highlight the words photo and you know
we searched four hundred developed we
highlight the word developed we had to
develop we highlight the word picture
probably photo little bit of mona
seefried in school pictures so we are
synonymous in the original query whose
photo and an industry salt so we're
Sonata mining this original query with
with dennis like picture with picture
photo developed that aren't exactly
represented in the users original
original query and because we're tuned
on lies and we're able to pull up a web
sites and results that might be higher
quality and that we think might be more
useful for for our users pictures and
photos is a pretty obvious example
though where it gets more here we go
where it gets more more interesting is
when we have to scale this to terms that
might mean something in different
contexts so we use the petabyte of web
documents that we have two billion
search queries that we have to to build
this intricate understanding of what
words can mean in different contests so
photos and pictures even can get more
complicated if I talk about if the query
of history of motion pictures a motion
picture is a concept right you wouldn't
want to synonym eyes motion pictures to
lotion photos that was imploded was in
an extent motion pictures doesn't make
sense you might want to tell lies motion
picture it says to movies right so a
great web page about the history of
movies would be it would be relevant to
to that query but page about photos is
probably not not relevant to that
beverage you wouldn't want to return it
and we can learn that through through
mining our web data mining our search
data and developing an understanding of
how language is used in different
contexts another example is is GM absent
of any context you might think GM means
General Motors but certainly if somebody
says GF cars that GM you would want to
expand to me to include documents that
simply they General Motors but what if I
said GM wheat right then maybe the
context there is that GM should mean
genetically modified wheat right there's
all kinds of other other meanings of
GM's well so if I the GM University and
I might interpret like George Mason
University ID of george mason university
or an NBA GM would be a general manager
so it's depending upon the contact you
might want an autumn eyes differently
and you can imagine that in order to be
able to do that at scale to the millions
of terms there are in english and all
the other languages we support we have
to be able to mind the data that we have
through the web and search love to to
make them work so what we do is
we look across the billions of searches
that we have and we apply different
algorithms to to data so for example one
of the approaches we take as we learn we
look to see how often users replace one
word with another in a particular
context so if I see the search queries
GM cars I might also see the search
query General Motors cards closely after
it and now I see that well the user
replace GM with General Motors and now
we think there's some relationship
between GM and General Motors we have to
be careful though because what often
happens as well is that somebody might
be shopping for different kinds of cars
so someone might type GM cars and then
they might also type BMW cars right and
we don't want to assume that GM and BMW
are synonyms but but that's awesome
vacation and that we see in our in our
love so it's one pattern of losses that
we would find by using that that
approach and and we have to address that
pattern of losses perhaps using another
algorithm or another signal that to help
us differentiate those cases and as part
of the process by which we we develop
changes is by thinking about an idea
running an experiment on that idea and
looking at these experiments that we run
these human evaluation in these live
experiments that we run to really
understand whether we're in general
doing the right thing and see what the
patterns of wins and losses are and if
we see a pattern of losses that that's
common among each of the lost examples
that we have then we can try to address
that and the follow-up change or even
try to modify our our algorithm to to
improve so finally one of the big wins
from using search queries as as a source
of information presented as opposed to
simply the web is that you're we're able
to incorporate and a colloquial language
usage of
idioms more easily than if we use formal
text so having a source of data that
matches the application that that we are
going to use that data is critical so
and we'll see how this plays out as well
actually when I talk about G board later
on the ideal case is that you're able to
use a source of data that's similar to
the to the context you're going to apply
it in 4G board we don't necessarily do
that in the first in the first iteration
and you'll see how how that what the
effective that is okay so the last thing
in ranking that I wanted to talk about
was was how we think about spam spam is
one of the early successes of us
building classifiers to help us
understand and detect websites that are
either actively trying to trick our BOTS
or that are hatched by yeah like that
half slice so they don't represent what
they used to or they they're trying to
SEO their content in a way that that
that that violates our guidelines so for
example can we detect whether a site has
been hacked and we have a classifier for
that or can we detect whether a slight
has hidden text search keywords stuff so
has words on the page that is invisible
to the user but they're they're simply
because that web master wants that page
to rank for those for those terms so
these are just a few examples of where
we use the the billions of documents on
the web billions of search queries that
we get to be able to build classifiers
that help us better understand whether a
page is potentially violating our
guidelines or or in general isn't isn't
useful for users because it's half tour
is cloaking or or whatnot so
some of them are easier to detect than
others but these are the different
problems that we face that that we build
that we both signals for algorithms for
and we run experiments for to determine
whether they're whether they're good
good enough in this section I wanted to
talk a little bit about our philosophy
when it comes to to search and how
machine learning fits into that
philosophy search is a global and
specific product search a Google search
is a global product that's used in
hundreds of 100 languages 100 countries
and it's important to the fabric of how
many people around the world get
information so a system of that scale
and that impact has to be human
understandable and the reason it has to
be human understandable is that we have
to understand as engineers at Google why
we return the results that we return why
we return the answers that we return we
have to understand why we return answers
that are correct as well as answers that
are incorrect so that we can understand
why things are working and why things
aren't working understanding our system
enables us to see why we're doing the
right and wrong things and fix these
patterns of problems by coming up with
new signals and new algorithms so when
we think about machine learning in
search we have to be conscientious of
the pros and cons that is that it brings
so has built systems where like Google
search ranking is largely today it's
human understandable so today for almost
any search query that you might issue I
or
another ranking engineer can can
understand why a particular result is
ranked or why a particular answer is
given in the first edition one common
issue with with machine to machine
learning is out of the box oftentimes
it's rather opaque or if you applied if
we apply to machine learned algorithm
for search we have a harder time
understanding well why did we why
exactly what signal was responsible for
us returning that answer now in some
contexts opaque systems are okay so for
example if the if the metric is is well
defined and agreed upon so there's a
very concrete metric to the the you know
a single metric that we that we can we
can trust as our true north as the way
that we think search is going to get
better then we maybe it's a little bit
more okay to have an opaque system
behind it because we can simply try to
optimize that single metric and know
that we're moving in the right direction
so in the context of a keyboard word
error rate might be might be that metric
how accurate are you with the keyboard
but relevance and search isn't really
well defined like our metrics and search
only capture a part of what our overall
user experiences we have cumin eval
metrics we have live experiment metrics
but each of these are limited in in what
they represent human evaluators don't
represent users users don't always know
what the most useful results are before
they before they click on them and they
have a hard time evaluating often times
what the most authoritative content is
so it's not an exact size then beyond
that like I mentioned earlier we have to
think about with respect to all of these
changes what's the impact on the
ecosystem were built on top of if we
make a particular change are we are we
promoting content farms from from to
develop more longtail low-quality
content or are we unfairly biasing large
prominent sights versus small sites that
might be equally authoritative and
equally high quality
and these are currently really measured
through live experiments they're not
directly measured through our human
evaluator some are and some are but both
the difficult problems so we need to
look at the exactly the individual very
example we need to understand what what
the patterns of wins and losses are and
try to make make a decision as to what
we think is the right the right change
but that says machine learning can bring
huge wins it allows us to encode
thousands of weak signals into a single
system that can put them together and
produce food is a very big win they can
do this by you know helping to identify
non-obvious ways to combine signals
signals that we wouldn't have thought to
just to include like or know if I have
any examples by certain certain terms
and the particular in the title of a web
page and it helps us scale our use of
data to plot to apply it to to apply
algorithms on and large large data sets
without through natural algorithms that
we're developing like our like our
google brain machine learned neural
networks so what we what we started to
do over the last year is is it's been
quite a bit more time thinking about
machine learning and thinking about how
we can build machine learned approaches
and tools and search that that we can
understand and that's the challenge that
we face and that's really where we're
spending a lot of our fun can we
understand how a machine learned
approach like ranks brain which is a
change an algorithmic change we launched
last year how that how that affects our
ranking what are the patterns of wins
and losses what exactly is it doing we
spend a lot of time understanding each
of the components to that to that neural
network and and making sure that we
think
to doing the right thing so simply using
machine learning applying it to an
objective function and launching it is
it certainly out of the question unless
we actually understand what's going on
so finally with respect to to search I
wanted to just focus a little bit more
on you know what the challenges we face
are whenever we do these eval they're
they're done on a cross section of the
current landscape of the third we take
the current web ecosystem and we run an
evaluation maybe for for a couple of
weeks as a live experiment we're on the
run d side by side human evaluation
experiments and we determine whether
it's a good thing or not but we have to
be conscientious to the fact that
changes to how we ranked content often
affects the ecosystem were built on top
of and some of these some of the effect
is intended you know we make changes to
encourage web developers to build mobile
friendly content or we make changes to
encourage developers to deep link their
apps so that users can directly navigate
to content within us or we make changes
to encourage developers to make their
sites faster and to make their sites
more secure by using HTTPS forsooth HTTP
so some of the changes we make we
intentionally encourage a directional
change on the ecosystem but far more we
have to think about what are the
unintended consequences in the long run
of some of the changes that we made so
this remains a challenge because we have
a hard time at a given point in time
predicting and understanding what the
long-term impact will be so there's a
very human element 22 what we think are
true north is and what we think a good
change is and that's still still in
place in a large part today even with
our focus on on machine learning
so I want to talk a little bit about a
little bit of G board g board with an
app that we just released a gvoice built
inside the search group mainly because
the technology that we use and I'm just
going to show you what G board g board
is is an app on iOS that you can
download on the App Store today it's a
keyboard that allows you to do something
called glides typing where you can drive
your finger around the keys and it'll
predict the words that you intended to
input and of course there's millions of
words and and we have to build and
understand length a language models for
these words to be able to do this
prediction and it's been searched
because you know in search we like I was
talking about earlier we think that we
understand language pretty well the
keyboard is a very different application
of this but still it uses similar
techniques to what we what we use in
speech recognition when you issue a
voice search to google and similar
techniques to what we think about when
we in when you I shoe a search word if
you believe in by us by typing it in and
so with G board you know you might you
might gesture a word and that registers
as touch point we have a particular
keyboard layout as our Android layout
but similar layout on iOS and then we
send it to our decoder and we have a
spatial model to understand well what's
the probability spatially that you meant
one character over or you you meant one
character over another and then we run
it through our language model which
helps us understand what the overall
likelihood of a particular word in the
context of the by Graham or the trigram
of the words before it and maybe even
after it our and then we provide
suggestions based on based on these
words here based on this model so if g
board though how we bootstrapped it was
by using words and sequences of words we
found we found on the web so these are
public words and when you download it
for the first time it's based on a model
that's largely trained on and on pages
that we find in the web we remind
billion
web documents build a language model to
understand the engrams that we see
commonly on the web and and use that as
our as our default model and then over
time what happens is it learns based on
your own words so you might use certain
colloquial phrases and it will learn the
your application of those phrases and
the by grams and track trigrams that you
use them in and so the quality improves
and it gets better over time simply
using your own your own data now of
course yeah like i mentioned earlier
with respect to synonyms using search
logs to improve sentence ideally it's
the case that we use conversational data
we use chat that we use keyboard data to
to improve our boots drafter or initial
language model and we're starting to
think about ways we can we can do that
so I think that's it for 4 tokes are one
more one more flat the other part of g
board i want to talk about are certain
new features that we built that involve
new ways of thinking about of how we can
mine our web data and one of them was
how how we built emoji search in emoji
predictions for emoji search and
predictions we were able to learn the
relationships between terms of the you
know grams and diagrams and particular
emoji characters based on how they're
used on the web and how users reference
those emoji and identify terms that we
that when typed in the conversation
could reflect that it could be replaced
by a particular mochi and that's how
moji predictions work and emoji search
works in g board today another feature
we have is something called predicted
searches where we've built completely on
device models to take as an input your
you're the worse that you're typing on
the keyboard and predict search queries
that we think might be relevant so for
example if you say hey you want to grab
lunch today then G board might suggest a
search query restaurants near me so that
you can find a restaurant and share it
with your friend the last feature in G
board is gift search and this is one of
the more popular features that users
have been using this is built off of our
core ranking algorithm so we're able to
scale and use the ipod web earlier with
anonyme you would spend with our poor
ranking functionality and apply that to
a restricted corpus within our image
search restricted to animated gifts and
that's that's how our gift search works
today so that's all I have for today I
believe we'll take some pressure off so
excited Rajan well let's turn to some of
the questions I think we'll just go more
or less in order that we receive them
I've been glancing through them wide
variety of questions first one is why
can't we see the knowledge graph pain
for President Obama when we search for
brock obama election in google and their
specific well yeah you know so maybe
you're asking me to debug the queer real
time but I i think you know ultimately
the goal is to show answers that we
think are useful for users given what we
think they want for particular query so
for brocco obama election i'm not sure
today what a user might want given that
his not not running again for president
but perhaps they're interested in
understanding what you might be talking
about with respect to the election and
in that case i would expect news article
rank as opposed to his his knowledge
dale hopefully they do let's see how can
you tell if the user some results they
liked versus they got frustrated and
bounds yeah this is a really hard
problem especially when we start to show
answers directly on the page and we and
a user might not need to click to get
the information they want so this is
something something where we're actively
working on today to better understand
that better develop metrics for this new
world of starts where we're trying to
provide answers we're trying to be
mobile first and users don't necessarily
need to click through
to a page to get what they what they
want another one specific technology or
software involve are you incorporating
word de Vaca vectors to understand the
information need in Google search you
know it's a big rip Google search so I'm
not sure who is that who is working on
what so it could be the case of somebody
working on applying word to that
somewhere somewhere at the heart google
but you know I personally I'm not a lot
of things going on again it's probably
there someplace okay are your changes
and improvements at Google sometimes
prompted by actual complaints or
unsolicited feedback from users yeah
this is i think is a really really good
question it is we internally as send
reports of problems we've experienced in
our own usage of google to the team and
and then we take we look at the feedback
that we get from real users it's
possible for any user to provide
feedback to the feedback link i believe
in the bottom of the search results page
and and we look at that and that's
actually what motivates almost all of
the experiments we run and the any
improvements that we make in terms of
data mining tools what tools you use are
they all internal or do you also use
third party tools most of the tools we
use our internal we use you know we
oftentimes write write code from the
ground up we have our own libraries for
data mining we we use MapReduce and some
of the some of the technologies we've
developed over the last 15 years at
Google every engineer though and that
position uses has their own approach not
everybody does things the right way sis
the same way and everyone ever
take takes their own approach to solving
a particular problem and they're free to
use you know whatever approach or
programming language they like skin and
yes there are a lot of right approaches
to do here's a question I actually have
done myself I think sometimes what about
connecting the language words I
presumably a search word to a thesaurus
or would this just be too crazy yeah so
you know I talked a little bit about
this the source would be very a very
limited way to understand anonyme simply
because it's hard to understand the
context with which and within which
these two words mean the same thing so
for example cats and cats don't even
always mean the same thing because cats
can can also be a Broadway musical and
proper names and so forth are really
represented in a source level let's see
what's next on our list here we did the
source one let's see as we change
induces of lang uses of language if we
look in Webster's dictionary there are
so many changes the word that never used
to be considered words the kind of like
very old school English I think that
we're still on a school in New York City
so I basically have you keep up with the
speed at which language is evolving its
etc yeah so it's great that we're able
to crawl and index the web very quickly
so now we're able to crawl and index web
pages within within seconds after
they're published as a new web pages use
new language and and search queries
users use new language when they when
the issue queries to Google and we're
able to use that data and keep our
models up-to-date with fresh simply by
refreshing our our our signals using
newer they were data newer web pages
into our search for ease just another
question along with that too when you
say soon something goes up
within a few seconds or may assume
you've crawled it attitude there are
links to that page or something
otherwise punku how do you find
something that yes aren't following like
we can discover webpages several ways we
want one weighs a webmaster is able to
push a sitemap to us another way is that
if that page might be linked to from
another page that we've already
discovered so if so most news publishers
push up the site map or tell us in some
way that a page was just published so
we're able to discover it problem that
fit very quickly especially from the
more popular higher-quality
authoritative question about misspelled
words how do you deal with words that
are intentionally misspelled for example
company names when it come up with
interesting spellings or variations on
words yeah this is a challenging problem
we are able to learn those words by
looking at what words are used on the
web so if there's a company name that's
spelled a different way we'll see that
word is on the web and we'll see that
users refer to that company by that that
that that that name and understand that
it must be a real concept a more general
question here on artificial intelligence
and sort of works taking us into the
future so regarding AI you're making a
learning system correct and if this is
probably developed what will check the
checks and balances be and can this
developing be considered a cyborg you
know we're building a ranking system you
know there are certainly people out
there that are building you know autos
like artificial intelligence systems and
learning systems I would consider our
system to be a ranking system our checks
and balances for our ranking system are
you know simply are we doing the right
thing for our users and are we doing the
right thing for the web ecosystem and
the abbey
system that were built on top of another
AI question why is Google obsessed with
AI or exactly do you think it's obsessed
with a high but yeah i mean i wouldn't i
wouldn't say google's obsessed with AI
but certainly machine learning and AI
can help us solve really hard problems
problems like can we build a
self-driving car and these aren't just
hard problems but they're important
problems but for for in terms of what
Google believe is important to work on
for the next 5 10 15 years a specific
question on g board how do you measure
how much the product has improved the
user experience room machine learning
yes it's a good question we we were able
to run evaluations similar to how we do
is in in search ranking we run
evaluations to see how easy it is to
type using the app and we we learn from
ourselves our own usage to see what our
experience has been with the app but no
matter what products you bill having a
good evaluation systems critical for for
knowing whether you're actually
improving it that's one of the first
things we set out to do with with the
keyboard and it's be bored available for
Android well you know we also have
google keyboard on android so we do have
a keyboard on android that you can get
from the Play Store it doesn't yet have
some of the functionality that that G
board for iphone has but we're looking
at seeing what the right with the right
products and user experiences for
Android and Windows Phone I don't
believe I'm not sure I don't believe we
have 140 so this question I my
understanding is that Google engineers
prefer to use neural networks over
machine learning techniques like GBM is
correct and if so why it's hard to
classify Google engineers in one bucket
they're there at Google there are
several independent teams that would
consider themselves to be machine
learning teams and each of them has
takes a different approach to learning
I'm not on those machine learning teams
we used only used a lot of those a lot
of research that they develop but but I
think they would be the best best people
answer that just interesting question
what are the main differences between
Google search over a public corpus
versus Google search over private corpus
such as Google Drive yeah you know the
one one big difference over a public
corpus is that there's simply a lot more
data and you're able to use that data
such as like the link graph and usage of
these pages to better understand how
what what these pages are about and how
authoritative they are 11 very you know
obvious difference is if you're
searching over a private corpus the
incentives for the publishers within
that corporates are very different so
searching over Google Drive you probably
don't have to worry as much about spam
or quality metrics as you would if you
are searching over a public corpus where
anybody can contribute content ok we
have a few more minutes left years let's
pick out a few more questions are using
machine learning as well to identify
improve utilized sounds and search
results for google voice search if you a
sort of the source of sources you're
using for selecting voice inputs and how
you collect them yeah we're
experimenting with with using machine
learning and various products at Google
I think including including voice again
I don't know the details of where
of what the does that we use but
certainly we are experiment with using
machine learning and more and more
products and what about the types of
algorithms used to scale to billions of
natural language sex yeah you know
there's the there's a large suite of
algorithms that we've developed to scale
to to the web sighs data and to and to
search queries size data the google rain
team has done quite a bit to to be able
to scale training neural networks to
billions and millions of inputs the
search the search ranking team does
quite a bit to make sure that the
algorithms they build scale to apply to
to the size of data we have but all
these others are very different there
they don't really follow lunch into a
single bucket so it's hard to hard to
group them but they're all kind of
unique and built from the ground up and
we'll how many of the new search
features who showed us will be part of
any newer version of the Google Search
Appliance in a new search feature in
reviving a textile I don't know if I
showed a new search feature I think
everything I showed is actually is out
there in production today so hopefully
it's up there Oh in the Google Search
Appliance the search of plant that Yoshi
I don't know I don't know very much
about the search appliance that I think
you're to be clear not talking about the
apps that you they use on the phone so I
don't know okay let's go look maybe two
more questions here a thing as a UX
designer a big challenges many
applications icon involved with helping
design is providing a comprehensive
internal site search tool this google
make their full Gotham available when a
website employees embedded google search
yeah so there's a product called custom
search engine that anyone can use it's
out there and it's built directly on top
of our core search algorithm and maybe
one final question then how does Google
search handle the Deep Web con
very interesting question along here and
yeah you know we don't do anything
specific we were built on top of the web
that we can discover and that and we
discover the web content through like I
mentioned earlier through through
sitemaps that webmasters may provide
through link graph through our link
graph that we crawl and and then the
same algorithms apply to all to all of
our web content we try to understand if
a site is high quality is authoritative
when we haven't try to understand if
that web page is this topical and fresh
for for for our users and if it meets
the bar across the topicality freshness
and authoritative miss and we can get
through a good useful useful page we
don't necessarily do apply different
algorithms for different kinds of
content and guys maybe 30 seconds one
final question because it's a search
related question how can new content
breaking the high ranking pages when it
doesn't have links rather signals yeah
trust of the rich get richer situation
yeah this is also a really good question
to another way to say this is like this
existing content get grandfathered in to
ranking for for certain queries and part
of our algorithm is actually focused on
making sure that we can surface great
new content that that is published to
the web so this is certainly a problem
that we had that we discovered or knew
about it for the left and you ever since
since we've had a search engine so spent
quite a bit of the last step few years
working to make sure that the best
content Rex well no matter what existed
previously okay well thank you Ron Jana
is very interesting and for those of you
still listening we will be sending out a
link to the slides and
webinar on the next day or so so be
looking for that if you want to review
it but otherwise we hope to see you
again in a sense or listening again to
one of our webinars in the future so
your bye for now from Stanford and hope
you have a great day
you